we've already talked about the life
cycle of stars roughly the same mass as
our Sun give or take a little bit what I
want to do in this video is talk about
more massive stars massive stars and
what I'm talking about massive stars I'm
talking about stars that have masses
greater than nine times greater than
nine times the Sun so the general idea
is exactly the same you're gonna start
off with this huge cloud of mainly
hydrogen and now this cloud is going to
have to be bigger than the clouds that
started that that that condensed to form
stars like our Sun but you're a start
with that and eventually gravity is
going to pull it together it's going to
put together and the core of it is going
to get hot and dense enough for hydrogen
to ignite for hydrogen to start fusing
so this is hydrogen and it is now fusing
let me write it it is now fusing
hydrogen fusion let me write it like
this you now have you now have hydrogen
fusion in the middle so it's it's
ignited and around it you have just the
other material of the cloud so the rest
of the hydrogen and now since it's so
heated it's really a plasma it's really
kind of a soup of electrons and
nucleuses as opposed to well formed
atoms especially close to the core so
now you have hydrogen fusion we saw this
happens to around 10 million Kelvin and
I want to make it very clear since we're
talking about more massive stars even at
this stage this is going to there's
going to be more more gravitational
pressure even at this even at this at
this stage during the main sequence of
this star because it is more massive and
so this is going to burn faster and
hotter so this is going to be faster and
hotter than something the mass of our
Sun faster and hotter and so even this
stage is going to happen much even in
over a much shorter period of time than
for a star the mass of our Sun our Suns
life is going to be 10 or 11 billion
total years here we're gonna be talking
about things and maybe the tens of
millions of years so a factor of a
thousand shorter life span but anyway
let's think about what happens and so
far just the pattern of what happens
it's going to happen faster because we
have more pressure more gravity more
temperature
but it's going to happen in pretty much
the same way as what we saw in the stock
with us are the mass of the Sun
eventually that helium sorry that
hydrogen is going to fuse into a helium
core that's going to have a hydrogen
shell around it it's going to have a
hydrogen shell around a hydrogen fusion
shell around and then you have the rest
of the star around that so let me label
it this right here is our helium core
and more and more helium is going to be
built up as this hydrogen and the shell
fuses and this is in a star the size of
our Sun or the mass of our Sun this is
when it starts to become a red giant
because this core is getting denser and
denser and denser as more and more
helium is produced and as it gets denser
and denser and denser there's more and
more gravitational pressure being put on
the hydrogen on this hydrogen shell out
here where we have fusion still
happening and so that's going to release
more outward energy to push out to push
out the radius of the actual star but
then when you fast forward there so the
general process and we're going to see
this as the star gets more and more
massive is we're gonna have heavier and
heavier elements forming in the core
those heavier and heavier elements as as
the star gets denser and denser will
eventually ignite kind of supporting the
core but because the the core itself is
getting denser and denser and denser
material is getting pushed further and
further out or with more and more energy
although with the Stars massive enough
it's not going to be able to be pushed
out as far as you will have in it kind
of a red giant was kind of a sun-like
star but let's just think about how this
pattern is going to continue so
eventually that helium is going to once
it gets dense enough it's going to
ignite and it's going to fuse into
carbon and you're going to have a carbon
core forming so that is carbon core
that's a carbon core around that you
have a helium core you have a helium
core and near the set near the center of
the helium core you have a shell of
healy of helium fusion that's helium not
hydrogen turning into carbon making that
carbon core denser and hotter and then
around that you have helium whew you
have hydrogen fusion have to be very
careful you have hydrogen fusion and
then around that you have the rest of
the star you have
the rest of the star and so this process
is going to keep continuing eventually
that carbons going to start fusing and
you're going to have heavier and have
your elements form the court and so this
is a depiction off of Wikipedia of a
fairly mature massive star and you keep
forming these shells of heavier and
heavier elements and cores of heavier
heavier male elements until eventually
you get to iron and in particular in
particular we're talking about we're
talking about iron 56 iron with an
atomic mass of 56 here on this periodic
table that 26 is it's atomic number it's
how many protons it has 56 is you can
kind of view it as a count of the
protons and neutrons although it's not
exact but at this point the reason why
you stopped here is that you cannot get
energy by fusing iron fusing iron into
heavier elements beyond iron actually
requires energy so it would actually be
an endothermic process so the fuse iron
actually won't won't help support the
core so what I want to do in this will
and so just just to be very clear this
is how the heavy elements actually
formed we started with hydrogen hydrogen
fusing into helium helium fusing into
carbon and then all of these things in
various combinations and I won't go into
all of the details are fusing heavier
and heavier elements neon oxygen and you
see it right over here silicon and these
aren't the only elements they're forming
but these are kind of the main core
elements they're forming but along the
way you have all this other stuff
lithium beryllium boron all of this
other stuff is also forming so this is
how you form elements up to iron 56 and
also actually this is actually how you
can form up to nickel-56 just to be
predict just to be exact there will also
be some nickel 56 which has the same
mass as iron 56 just has two fewer
neutrons and two more protons so it's
nickel-56 will also form can also kind
of be it'll be a nickel iron core but
that's about how far a star can get
regardless of how how massive it is at
least by going through traditional
fusion through the traditional ignition
mechanism what I want to do is leave you
there and think of it just so you can
think about what might happen next now
that we can't fuse this star anymore and
what we're actually going to see is it
will
supernovae